let's talk about this nine million
followers they're mostly kim's combined
combined still it's it's an amazing
number and what i've noticed about you
ladies that you will dispense very
provocative advice sometimes i think
just for fun not you you don't do corny
and chloe do it's time to smelly unified
by us so kim you're above this you don't
do it but courtney and chloe like to
dispense sort of racy advice to fans who
take it seriously you guys realize that
most of our fans are under the age of 18
and that you guys are bad influences
that we're teaching chloe i'm trying to
teach people one that twitter has been
taken way too seriously and like talking
about putting the
mayonnaise on your thing is not
appropriated
honestly women need to know how to take
care of their stuff
i'm not even here anymore i just
i'm wearing
i'm wearing jeggings listening to you
guys talking about putting mayonnaise
down there and i'm just i don't know
what's happened but we some people ask
us like why would you want to put
mayonnaise down
truck just a little bit you can't you
can't move ahead from that statement
you you advised women to people we
didn't advise club i told chloe that
they don't really do this and it's a
joke and they've never how do you know
i actually do this chloe that i found
her sex mask under my bed that she's
been looking for and then she wrote me
back oh my god i found your jar of
mayonnaise that you use on your vagina
and then i said and then we were talking
back and forth and people are like what
does mayonnaise on your vagina do and we
said it makes it shine like the top of
the chrysler building
why would you want a shiny vagina anyway
i don't know
uh
um uh wow okay and so
so people heard this that was a joke
[Laughter]
i'm gonna need some time during the
commercial break
well this is so kim they do these things
this isn't your you don't love this do
you i just don't think it's appropriate
to talk about stuff like that especially
to twitter on twitter or you know any
public place where young girls follow at
your own risk
you know this isn't me you guys just you
you've come to our sh we haven't even
met you're fighting with each other
instantly this is fantastic i love it uh
uh uh you courtney you love to embarrass
kim do you not you just love to
embarrass her well since you were kids
we're 18 months apart so i always like
if she was talking to boys on the phone
or something she developed before i did
at like 10 i had big boobs and she'd get
on the phone and go kim has huge tits
[Laughter]
and it was so
i mean you'll say that but you won't
talk about mayonnaise i'm repeating
something she said
i'm repeating something she said sorry
it's louise used to torture her like
torture me growing up okay so you would
shout out on the phone first of all
don't people who know kim already know
that
hey here's the secret she's got big
boobies see i mean
[Applause]
the word's out
here's the scoop it's on wikileaks check
it out
uh you uh ladies are very savvy about
business and uh you're you're terrific
business women you get offered a lot of
endorsement deals
and you've turned down a lot of things
what are some of the things that you've
said can't do it it's just too i can't
do it
i've got an offered lube
to endorse lube
lube
and i turned it jiffy lube you know get
your car
good old lube okay i've gotten offered
um
butt enhancement pills
that i've turned who wants to give you
butt enhancement pills yeah i don't know
are there do they work i mean i don't
know like that yeah she definitely tries
okay yeah we got it anything we get it i
yes
yes we
we get it i have no ass
america
laugh it up